le rapport la dpj pour la demande
d'accès lorsqu'on compte 18 ans ce
rapport contient les détails de la vie
de gabrielle d'arquennes de 8 à 18 ans
dix années de vie instable et pourtant
il est mince avec bien les oublis dans
ce thème la dpj présentement on va dans
une pente descendante
ce s'améliore pas ça s'améliore pas non
il ya des améliorations tu l'avais
traite mais hier rien qui ait fait la
dpj arrive quand ses parents se séparent
tous deux coups tout bascule avance on
avait une belle histoire familiale tout
allait bien mon masque on faisait du
sport des activités régulières que du
jour au lendemain la séparation robes
briser le lien familial les deux parents
sont séparés la compagnie est tombé
violences conjugales troubles de
comportement plus d'une dizaine de va et
vient entre les parents les foyers
centres d'accueil
rien ne va plus j'appelle la détention
jld une aile en fait lorsqu'on parle à
son accès fermé
on peut comparer ça à un système
militaire régimes totalitaires plus
encore il déplore que rien ne soit fait
pour les parents sa mère était
alcoolique
son père a fini par disparaître mais à
l'école ils se débrouillaient il
s'accrochait si bien qu'à 27 ans
aujourd'hui
après avoir été abandonné à lui-même à
18 ans par la dpj et travaillé pendant
des années pour subvenir au strict
minimum
il est sur le point de compléter un
diplôme en droit à l'université d'ottawa
pour s'occuper des enfants judiciariser
j'avais un rêve je le donnais avocat
j'ai toujours tenu depuis longtemps puis
je me suis accroché à ses règles et je
me suis dit peu importe que ça prendra
je vais y arriver ici la résilience
prend tout son sens à tous les jours que
j'ai des collèges fait l'aller retour de
question de moyens et de retrouver une
stabilité avec sa copine près de
montréal et abriel prend le train où il
étudie et réfléchis y est très beaucoup
de situations que j'ai vécu qui m'emmène
à à penser rétrospectivement à ce que
j'ai vécu pour pouvoir le mettre en
application la bonne manière
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il appelait d'il
ya un peu plus d'un mois devant le
ministre délégué à la santé et aux
services sociaux ou lionel carmant quand
il a pu le rencontrer
par un concours de circonstances ce
serait peut-être là la formation des des
intervenants sociaux
ce que c'est eux qui sont toujours là
avec les jeunes ce serait de les aider à
les supporter patates avec des
malformations patates avec les agents
troubles tels de ressources à ce niveau
là ce que la dpj vous a volé votre
adolescence absolument absolument
il manque des ressources au mois pour
faire du sport en attendant jour
basketball le fallait j'ai
l'autorisation d'un juge
on vous élève pas comme un enfant normal
tandis que les enfants ce qu'ils ont
besoin à ce moment là c'est de l'amour
ça vous séparer de votre famille on n'a
rien fait pour ainsi demeurer unis
remonte nasa rien ne prédestinait
gabriel à repartir dans la vie avec un
diplôme de droit en poche il espère
maintenant faciliter la vie à d'autres
qui comme lui à une autre époque se
heurte à une enfant c'est possible et si
matthew zions radio canada longueuil